[Music]
hey dom listen you need to have a goal
you need to look at look at some
aspect in life and say this is what i
want to be you should put all your
aspects and all your determination in
your will to reach that that goal and
that's just what i always did i didn't
know i wanted to be a fighter until i
see muhammad ali when i was at a
reformatory and it just snapped i didn't
think i wanted to be anything don but a
criminal and i saw muhammad ali
and my whole life changed and that could
happen to you too you just have to be
inspired you have to look at things you
have to read things you have to want to
accomplish great things in life you have
to look at yourself
as a great accomplisher of life you're
winning in life and with that mentality
there's gonna always be disappointments
you have to know be able to get
discouraged that's what life is all
about how much you can take how much how
much you can get but how much you can
really take and not get discouraged and
give up
[Music]
hey jion listen it's very difficult for
me to say but you can't really judge
your siblings because
in all actuality
people are just not made to handle
tragedy
and sometimes you're born with the gifts
to be able to rise to the occasion and
run the whole situation and by you doing
that
they're chip in because they see your
audacity and they want to chip in and
you give them the inspiration to want to
participate
[Music]
hey andres um to answer your question i
love the time that i was born
um it was written for me to be born at
this particular time and it's just
impossible to even imagine that i always
ask people what do you think the history
was us in funny clothes or what
and they always get stuck by that one
[Music]
hey sonny listen um
cuss was more on the mystic level he
read books like zen
and then an art of archery and books
like that war and peace he was just one
of those guys but he was really
interested in um
affirmations
the way that um the affirmation the way
emailed kuwait
he didn't invent them they've been doing
this before christ but he made it very
worldwide well spread affirmations i
love myself i can accomplish anything
i'm a god
and that became very
widespread to
email kuwait
[Music]
hey julian listen the best pictures for
me i think to get for beginners are
rolling pigeons they're the easiest bird
to train
and the hardest bird for someone else to
catch
so it's just um a no-brainer rolling
pigeons
[Music]
logan you need to bend your legs and
lean more forward just straight up um
the people's style is known as almost
like crab technique in japanese karate
you're handing them your hands up
and you're jabbing you're punching and
you're moving as you're coming in and
you're very aggressive you're constantly
putting pressure on someone
it's never done going backwards
only
only forward and side to side never
backwards
you